Corey this is a piece that you wrote in
2020 inflation-adjusted K-12 education
spending per student has increased by
280 percent since 1960.
um you know so uh on average the U.S
spends over 15 grand a year per student
um where has that money gone because
that you know and this is
inflation-adjusted so it's you know it's
not simply because everything is more
expensive than in 1960 what are what are
the main components of per pupil
spending
yeah look and that is from June of 2020
um so that the spending is a lot higher
now even than it was in 2020 because of
all the so-called coveted relief I think
we've pumped 190 billion dollars in in
so-called coveted relief into the K-12
School System since March of 2020 which
is over three or four thousand dollars
per student so we spend a lot more now
than we did then and even then if you
just look between 1970 and
um 2019 with the latest Federal data
that we have nationwide uh per student
with increased pers per student
education expenditures by uh 152 percent
over that period and teacher salaries
since 1970 have increased only by about
eight percent so it's not going towards
the teachers in the classroom it's going
more towards Staffing surges and
administrative blow if you look at a
report by Ben scaffidy back to the
Staffing surge he looks at different
periods of time finding that uh the the
number of support staff in particular re
raises exponentially in in different
locations whereas student enrollment and
teachers in this in the buildings is
pretty stagnant and I think that's
because the current school system is a
one-size-fits-all monopoly that has no
incentive to spend additional dollars
wisely so they put it towards more
people because more employees means more
dues paying members for the the teachers
unions which means more money for people
like Randy Weingarten who make over five
hundred thousand dollars a year so even
even uh but it's not even going to
teachers it's going to staff who then
end up joining unions
that's right and if you look between uh
there's a been a image that goes around
on Twitter pretty pretty uh often that I
was the first one to create it I didn't
put my name on it I probably should have
but it's a graph between
2000 and 2019 using Federal data sources
finding that the number of students in
the system increased by about seven
percent the number of teachers in the
system similar about seven or eight
percent but then the number of
administrative staff increased by about
80 percent so looking at different
periods we find the same uh what are
what are those people doing what are
what are the support staff what are the
non-instructional staff doing
well they uh a whole host of different
things
um so in Los Angeles for example uh
since 2019 they had a plan to of what to
do with the additional 69 percent of
spending that was going into the Los
Angeles Public Schools and the latest uh
report that I saw showed a an increase
of counselors by about uh 80 percent and
an increase in in teaching staff by much
lower lower number while student
enrollment over the same period was
projected to decrease by about six
percent so in what other industry do you
lose your customers lose six percent of
your customers and then start hiring
more and more people with Los Angeles
Public Schools now spending uh in the
latest budget I believe over twenty five
thousand dollars per student so they're
just a whole host of different you know
they're trying to make the schools
um and they can they can they can lay
out arguments as to why it might be a
good idea to have more counselors
because while we closed the schools and
we heard the kids mentally so now we've
got to fix the problems that we created
by hiring more counselors yeah and so
they just
um yeah they'll throw everything at the
wall see what sticks and and hire as
many people as they can in any position
yeah go ahead Connor I was just going to
add briefly and tie us back to your uh
slide with the SAT scores what's
especially compelling about the data
that Corey is describing is that if you
look at the test scores across the same
period of time whatever chunks of time
you want to look at the test scores are
flat now Corey and I you know are we
don't believe that standardized testing
is the you know some bonum of
educational attainment but it is an
effective way to try and at least assess
lightly uh what the performance looks
like and test scores have not gone up so
the the increases in investment and the
administrative class of these schools
may have its perks may have its uh
stated purposes but it's not trickling
down to improving the education of the
students and that I think is what's most
compelling about the problem is that uh
we're we're chasing uh you know putting
bad money into a system that isn't
ultimately serving the ideal uh customer
for which it purportedly exists and so
we say we say in the book ultimately
that why do schools exist now it's not
to educate students it's a jobs program
for adults and the unions defending that
is ultimately its core value proposition
at this point and these are just SAT
scores for college-bound seniors
um in 1963 68 73 and 78 so kind of the
years before that and you see declines
consistently through that more recently
um because I want to get to you know
that's 40 years ago we're essentially
looking at 80 years of kind of uh
collapse Corey can you talk a little bit
about what what were the emphases on
school reform or education reform uh
starting in the in the 1980s into the
early 90s
a lot of this was uh accountability
mechanisms and mostly focused on
standardized tests uh but what I want to
say is that
the the failures have have changed and
have become much Beyond much further
Beyond uh what can be captured by a
standardized test score and what we're
seeing more recently is and what we
highlight in the book is a lot of the
non-academic failures of the school
system too such as them being controlled
by the teachers unions and
indoctrination that's happening in the
schools as well uh and just having a
one-size-fits-all system that doesn't uh
will never meet the individual needs of
families who disagree about how they
want their kids raised and I think
that's what we've seen a lot over the
past couple of years and we've seen some
pushes from the top down to control the
curriculum from one side and we've seen
other reformers such as myself pushing
from the bottom up to create more um of
a thousand flowers blooming approach a
free market approach that was an excerpt
from reasons live stream with Corey
DeAngelis and Conor boyak the authors of
mediocrity 40 ways government schools
are failing today's students if you want
to see the full conversation go here if
you want to see another excerpt go here
and make sure to come back next Thursday
every Thursday at 1 pm eastern time when
Zach wise Miller and I are doing a live
stream with somebody very interesting
that you are definitely going to want to
know about